всё бля
ха And on the first day he started to panic a lot,
he cried and asked me all
the time if they won't kill me or if we will live
[music] we
have two very beautiful forests in which,
if we were growing up,
we would always walk with our children, go for
mushrooms just on  rest,
being here, I want to remember to see
how people swim and I want to remember how
I swam, the
question of the Butterfly distance at the
Paralympic Games in Beijing in 2008
[music]
we
bought a big apartment in 2021,
renovated it, bought all new modern furniture
[music]
I told the children  case, we gather
things and went to bed and in the morning the
war has already started
[music] on
February 24 we woke up not from ordinary
houses to work,
only the lives of our children and the safety of
our children are worth it, I have two children, a
boy 7 years old and a
daughter 1 year old
and as it became more and more dangerous  we
made such a decision with my husband,
who has remained in Ukraine for the time being,
we made such a decision that we need to
leave Kyiv for seven hours, that is, what
we did before the war was 40 minutes, this time it
was 7 hours and for 27 hours we drove without
stopping and did not sleep  they didn't eat anything
in the bedroom, I was invited by my rival
Tereza ferralis February 25 We
drove to the
border with Moldova and Natasha moved to
our acquaintances with the children moved to
our acquaintances in Moldova
when we arrived in Berlin
everything was like a fog I can't even
to say that we understood the decisions we were
making and we
went on to Lviv and then we went
to Portugal because we had
acquaintances there but they
could help us with housing if not for a long time
And we decided to
go to Poland
[music]
of course  The European Union
is doing a lot for Ukraine
itself. Ukraine would hardly be able to
withstand this influx without it.
I am very grateful to the European
countries for helping us. There are only
hopes to return home
soon, let it be already, if there is nowhere to
return to. Well, it’s okay, if we were young, we would
still rebuild it.  i think i miss
my husband
[music]